"AMERICA'S NEWSROOM" AND
TUCKER IS UP NEXT.
♪
>> Tucker: WELL, GOOD
AND, OF COURSE, HAPPY NEW
12 MONTHS AS THE BEST
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
IT WAS A TURBULENT YEAR AND
2018 COULD BE EVEN MORE SO.
LATER TONIGHT ADVICE ON HOW
TO THRIVE OVER THE YEAR
AHEAD NO MATTER WHAT
HAPPENS.
BUT, FIRST, THIS COUNTRY'S
LARGEST STATE HAS TAKEN
ANOTHER DRAMATIC STEP
TOWARDS DISUNION.
AN OPEN DEFIANCE OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AS OF YESTERDAY, CALIFORNIA
IS NOW A SANCTUARY STATE.
IT'S THE NATIONst FIRST.
ASKING ABOUT A SUSPECT'S
IMMIGRATION STATUS OR
COOPERATING WITH FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION OFFICIALS.
LAND LORDS ARE BANNED FROM
REPORTING THE LEGAL STATUS
OF THEIR TENANTS.
COLLEGES CAN'T MONITOR THE
IMMIGRATION STATUS OF THE
KIDS THEY ENROLL.
THESE MEASURES AUGMENT THE
STATE'S MANY EXISTING LAWS
ALL DESIGNED TO ENABLE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
ILLEGALNESS CALIFORNIA ARE
ALREADY COMBINE ENTITLED TO
RECEIVE DRIVERS LICENSE.
INSTATE FREE TUITION
HEALTHCARE AND JOB.
DOESN'T MATTER IF THEY HAVE
A HISTORY OF CRIME, EVEN
VIOLENT CRIME.
IN CALIFORNIA ILLEGAL ALIENS
ARE NOW PRESS SECRETARY
IS NOW IN DIRECT OPPOSITION
TO THIS COUNTRY'S MOST BASIC
LAWS.
55 YEARS AGO THIS MONTH,
GOVERNOR GEORGE WALLACE TOOK
HIS OATH OF OFFICE AND
PLEDGED RESISTANCE TO
FEDERAL AUTHORITY.
EFFECTIVELY DECLARING
ALABAMA ITS OWN COUNTRY.
YOU KNOW THE HISTORY.
WELL, GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN
OF CALIFORNIA HAS DONE
SOMETHING SIMILAR THIS WEEK.
TRAVIS ALLEN IS A REPUBLICAN
IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
MR. ALLEN, THANKS FOR COMING
ON.
>> THANKS SO MUCH, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: CALIFORNIA IS THE
BIGGEST STATE BUT STILL A
STATE, NOT A COUNTRY.
HOW CAN IT HAVE ITS OWN
IMMIGRATION POLICY?
HOW DID K. IT REDEFINE
CITIZENSHIP WHEN IT'S
THOUGHT A COUNTRY?
>> SIMPLY PUT, IT CAN'T.
THIS WHOLE SANCTUARY STATE
IS ENTIRELY ILLEGAL.
WE ARE ACTUALLY WELCOMING
>> Tucker: HOW DOES THIS
END?
I MEAN, WHEN STATES DECLARE
PUBLICLY WE'RE NOT FOLLOWING
THE LAWS OF THE COUNTRY, WE
ARE MAKING OUR OWN LAWS AND
THERE IS NOTHING YOU CAN DO
ABOUT IT, THAT SOUNDS LIKE
THE BEGINNING OF A SCHISM, A
I MEAN, CALIFORNIA TRULY HAS
BECOME THE CENTER OF THE
QUOTE UNQUOTE RESISTANCE TO
THE PRESIDENT.
AND EVERYTHING THAT SEEMS TO
MAKE COMMON SENSE IN THE
RECENT ACTION OF THE
SANCTUARY STATE, CALIFORNIA
ANS DON'T EVEN AGREE WITH
THIS.
POLITICIANS THAT RUN THE
STATE IN SACRAMENTO.
THE LEGISLATURE UNTIL
RECENTLY WAS TWO THIRDS
DEMOCRAT AND ALL OF THE
STATEWIDE OFFICERS ARE
DEMOCRAT AS WELL.
PASSED THIS LAW EVEN THOUGH
CALIFORNIANS ARE ABSOLUTELY
AGAINST IT.
>> Tucker: WHAT'S SO
STRIKING IN THE SPECIFIC
MIDDLE CLASS.
THEY ARE MOVING TO
NEIGHBORING STATES, NORTH
AND EAST IS IN HUMAN
NUMBERS.
IT'S BEEN WRITTEN ABOUT A
LOT.
THE STATE DOESN'T SEEM TO
CARE.
EVEN AS THIS HAPPENS SEEMS
TO BE IMPORT AGO NEW MUCH
>> YOU KNOW, I REALLY DON'T
KNOW THAT THERE IS A
RECENTLY 243,000
CALIFORNIANS HAVE LEFT IN
JUST THE LAST FEW YEARS,
TAKING ABOUT $8 BILLION WITH
THEM.
BURGEONING ILLEGAL
POPULATION WHICH NOW AS YOU
MENTIONED HAS PROTECTED
CLASS STATUS.
AND IT GETS VERY BAD BECAUSE
TO SHELTER CRIMINALS WHO ARE
COMMITTING CRIMES WHILE THEY
ARE HERE.
POLICE OFFICER.
DOMESTIC BATTERY.
ANIMAL CRUELTY, POSSESSION
OF CONCEALED WEAPONS U
BIOLOGICAL AGENTS.
I MEAN, THESE ARE REAL
CRIMES AND, YET, JERRY BROWN
THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATS
WANT TO ESSENTIALLY IGNORE
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION LAW AND
PROTECT THESE PEOPLE AT
CALIFORNIA'S EXPENSE.
AND THAT'S JUST WRONG.
TUCK IGNORING IMMIGRATION
BECAUSE IT GETS TO THE
DEEPEST QUESTION ABOUT ANY
COUNTRY WHICH IS WHO IS A
CITIZEN AND WHO IS NOT.
WHO DESERVES TO BE HERE AND
WHO DOESN'T, WHAT ARE
BORDERS?
AND SO CALIFORNIA CAN'T, YOU
GOVERNOR CAN'T EXPECT THIS
TO GO IGNORED.
YOU CAN'T JUST DECIDE YOU
ARE NOT GOING TO ENFORCE THE
BORDERS AND EXPECT
WASHINGTON TO DO NOTHING.
IS THERE A SHOWDOWN COMING?
>> ABSOLUTELY THERE IS.
I MEAN, THIS IS TRULY --
IT'S A BLUFF.
AND IT'S UP TO THE PRESIDENT
AND JEFF SESSIONS TO STEP IN
A LOT OF PEOPLE AROUND THE
COUNTRY SAY WELL, EVERYBODY
IN CALIFORNIA IS LIBERAL.
THEY ARE DEMOCRAT.
THERE COULD BE NOTHING
FURTHER FROM THE TRUTH.
THERE IS ACTUALLY MORE
REPUBLICANS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THAN IN ANY OTHER
PARTY LINES FOR A MOMENT.
ABSOLUTELY AGAINST SANCTUARY
STATE.
INCLUDING 65% OF LATINOS.
>> Tucker: WHY WOULD THEY BE
FOR IT?
MIDDLE CLASS ISN'T LEAVING
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE IT'S
THRIVING.
THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS A
MESS.
THE SCHOOLS ARE TERRIBLE.
UNION.
I MEAN, IS THERE A
CONNECTION, DO YOU THINK,
BETWEEN THE STATE WANTS
IMMIGRATION POLICIES AND THE
DIRECTION OF ITS ECONOMY?
>> WITHOUT A DOUBT.
AND, I MEAN, REALLY, YOU
HAVE TO GO BACK A COUPLE OF
DECADES.
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
HAS BEEN DOMINATED BY
THE BROWN FAMILY HAS RUN
CALIFORNIA FOR 24 OF
SO, YOU NEED TO LOOK TO NO
FURTHER THAN WHAT HAS BEEN
GOING ON SUCCESSFULLY WE HAD
DRIVERS LICENSES FOR
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS,
THE NEXT STEP.
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
BUT THE CALIFORNIA LEGAL
SYSTEM IS BROKEN.
CALIFORNIA POLITICAL SYSTEM
IS BROKEN.
THAT'S WHY WE TRULY NEED
WASHINGTON TO HEAR THIS
MESSAGE AND COME TO
CALIFORNIA.
SUE CALIFORNIA, TAKE THEM TO
SUPREME COURT AND LET'S GET
THE CONSTITUTION ENFORCED.
THERE IS A LOT OF
CALIFORNIANS HERE THAT WANT
TO BE PROTECTED.
UNTIL WE GET NO A NEW
GOVERNOR IN STATE.
YOU KNOW I'M RUNNING TO BE
THE NEXT GOVERNOR OF
CALIFORNIA, UNTIL THAT
HAPPENS WE COULD ACTUALLY
NEED SOME HELP FROM THE
FOR JOINING US.
>> WITHOUT A DOUBT, TUCKER.
WHAT STARTS HERE IN
LET'S PUT A STOP TO IT.
CATHY ROUX IS THE PUBLISHING
EDITOR OF MAGAZINE U THANKS
FOR COMING ON.
CAN YOU AGREE OR NOT WITH
THE NEW POLICY IN
CALIFORNIA.
BUT DOESN'T IT GIVE YOU
PAUSE THAT CALIFORNIA IS
BASICALLY DOING WHAT
SOUTHERN STATES DID 50 YEARS
AGO, 60 YEARS AGO IN SAYING
WE'RE IGNORING FEDERAL
AUTHORITY ON STATES RIGHTS
GROUNDS, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT YOUR SLAW
VALID.
LIBERALS USED TO BE AGAINST
THAT THEY ARE NOT ANYMORE.
>> IT'S QUITE THE OPPOSITE.
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO HANDLE
IMMIGRATION AND ASK FOR
PAPERS.
IF ANYTHING THEY ARE GIVING
AUTHORITY BACK TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NOT
TAKING IT IN THEIR OWN
HANDS.
>> Tucker: NO.
BECAUSE THERE ARE MANY
SPECIFIC CASES WHERE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS A
MATTER OF POLICY HAS REFUSED
TO HAND OVER AND THIS LAW
CODIFIES IT CRIMINALS TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THEY ARE REFUSING TO
COOPERATE WITH FEDERAL LAW.
THEY ARE SAYING WE ARE
NOT -- WE DON'T ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT LAW AS VALID.
HOW IS THAT DIFFERENT FROM
WHAT GEORGE WALLACE SAID?
>> NO.
IT'S NOT LIKE THAT AT ALL.
AND AS A MATTER OF FACT,
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST STATE
TO BECOME A SANCTUARY STATE
OR.
>> Tucker: IT IS.
>> OREGON IS A SANCTUARY
STATE AND OREGON IS ONE OF
THE SAFEST STATES IN OUR
UNIONS.
SANCTUARY STATES AND UNIONS
ARE SOME OF THE SAFEST PLACE
TO BE IN THE UNITED STATES.
>> Tucker: THAT'S SIMPLY NOT
TRUE.
>> YES IT IS.
>> RIGHT.
OKAY.
>> Tucker: LET ME ASK YOU
THOUGH CALIFORNIA
♪ ONE OF THE SAFEST CITIES
THE STATE IN MANY PLACES ARE
SHAPE MORE POVERTY AND
HOMELESS PEOPLE IN THAT
STATE THAN ANY OTHER STATE.
AND CALIFORNIA DOESN'T
HOUSE -- 67% OF ALL THE
HOMELESS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
PEOPLE FROM ANOTHER COUNTRY
ANOTHER COUNTRY AREN'T
EXACTLY HURTING THE SYSTEM
IN ANY SINGLE WAY.
THEY WOULDN'T BE HERE IF THE
WORK AND THE JOBS WERE NOT
HERE, SO THESE PEOPLE ARE
NOT RURETTING OUR SYSTEM?
>> Tucker: REALLY?
BECAUSE THERE ARE 135,000
HOMELESS PEOPLE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY --
>> -- IMMIGRANTS?
>> Tucker: HAVE NO JOBS.
HAVE NO HOMES.
>> OKAY.
>> Tucker: ARE LIVING
OUTSIDE, OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF THEM AND, YET,
STATE?
WHY SHOULDN'T THE STATE BE
ATTENDING TO THEIR NEEDS
IMMIGRANTS IN ANY WAY.
THESE IMMIGRANTS ARE HERE.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE GIVING
THEG THEM DRIVERS LICENSE,
THEY ARE PAYING FOR
HEALTHCARE, INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> IMMIGRANTS PAY TAXES.
THEY DO.
>> Tucker: ACTUALLY, HOLD
ON, EVERY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
WORKING IN THIS COUNTRY IS
USING FAKE FEDERAL DOCUMENTS
ILLEGALLY.
THAT'S A FELONY BY THE WAY.
FAKE DOCUMENTS.
THEY ARE NOT ALL PAYING
TAXES.
YOU KNOW THAT'S NOT TRUE.
STATE ATTEND TO THEIR NEEDS
CALIFORNIA THAN LIVE IN THE
ENTIRE CITY OF DAYTON, OHIO.
THAT'S A LOT OF PEOPLE.
>> IMMIGRANTS PAY MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN TAXES.
THEY ARE HELPING THE STATE
AND THEY WOULDN'T BE THERE
IF IT WASN'T WORK.
SO IF THERE IS ANYONE'S
PROBLEM ARE THE CORPORATIONS
THAT ARE HIRING THESE
IMMIGRANTS.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON.
WHAT ABOUT THE CALIFORNIANS
WHO ARE BORN THERE.
>> RIGHT.
>> Tucker: WHO ARE
NATURALIZED AMERICANS BORN
>> RIGHT.
>> Tucker: DON'T HAVE WORK.
AGAIN, LIVING OUTSIDE.
PLIGHT MORE IMPORTANT.
>> WHO IT TO SAY THE
PLIGHT'S ISN'T NUMBER ONE.
THE UNDOCUMENTED PERSON'S
PLIGHT ISN'T NUMBER NUMBER.
SANCTUARY STAY NIGHT TAKE
THAT THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
TELL THESE PEOPLE YOU ARE
NOT WANTED HERE.
YOU ARE NOT WORKING, YOU ARE
NOT BEING PRODUCTIVE.
NOT HELPING OUR SOCIETY.
THEY ARE SAYING BE PART OF
OUR COMMUNITY.
CALL IN THE CRIME.
FEEL SAFE HERE.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON.
WHY DOESN'T THE GOVERNOR
PEOPLE LIVING OUTSIDE IN
CALIFORNIA, THE AMERICAN
CITIZENS LIVING OUTSIDE
HELPING THEM?
>> HE IS HELPING EVERYONE BY
MAKING THESE PEOPLE FEEL
WELCOME IN HIS STATE.
IT HELP AMERICANS OR
CALIFORNIANS IN THIS CASE
WITHOUT JOBS TO WELCOME
PEOPLE TO WORK FOR LESS THAN
THEY WOULD MAKE.
HOW DOES IT HELP THEM.
>> UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
ARE NOT HURTING ANYONE'S
JOBS.
NOT TAKING AWAY ANYONE'S
WE NEED MORE WORKER VISAS
FOR THESE PEOPLE WE DON'T
HAVE A SYSTEM.
>> Tucker: I'M SORRY.
I'M TRYING TO BE PATIENT AND
TRACK WITH YOU LOGICALLY.
>> OF COURSE.
PEOPLE UNEMPLOYED HELPFUL TO
THOSE PEOPLE, THE AMERICAN
UNEMPLOYED TO BRING IN A
WHOLE LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE
AND GIVE THEM JOBS?
HOW DOES THAT HELP THE
UNEMPLOYED IN AMERICA?
I'M TOTALLY BAFFLED?
>> WHAT IS HURTING IS
TECHNOLOGY AND THE
MANUFACTURING JOBS ARE GONE
AND TECHNOLOGY IS HURTING
IMMIGRANT.
>> Tucker: IF TECHNOLOGY IS
MAKING ALL THE LOW WAGE JOBS
GO AWAY, THEN WHY ARE WE
LETTING IN HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS NATIONALLY
>> WELL, IMMIGRATION IS AT
AN ALL-TIME LOW.
>> NO, ACTUALLY BIGGER IN
THE 1970S, IT IS LOWER NOW
THAN EVER.
>> Tucker: THAT'S NOT TRUE,
ACTUALLY.
TECHNOLOGY IS MAKING IT
HARDER FOR PEOPLE WHO DON'T
HAVE ADVANCED TECH SKILLS.
>> RIGHT.
>> Tucker: TO FIND WORK.
>> THEY ARE PROBABLY NEEDED.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE GOING TO
BE DISPLACED BY TECHNOLOGY.
>> RIGHT NOW THEY ARE
NEEDED.
THESE WORKERS ARE NEEDED
YEAR AROUND AND WE NEED
VISAS FOR THESE TYPE OF